good morning on board the Explorer and
greetings from the M room they say that
Size Doesn't Matter takeing enough in
three 2 1 here we
[Music]
go but in this case it kind of does one
of the ways we're reducing risk when
flying drones like this is to make sure
we have a wide stable platform and
that's why we're on this big boat right
now big
ship the captain's going to kill
[Music]
me
land this
370t Expedition ship is home for the
next month how are you doing yo cuz do
you know how big they are they're like
the bo 737 seven of the planet Earth if
you want to know how to fly like an
albatross they have one very nice trick
that will lock their wings ask an
ornithologist so if you imitate me so
another foot is it will be that big can
you imagine a bird this is the biggest
on the planet Earth
wow Javier's travel the world studying
Birds oh my goodness but he's never
flown like one let's go for it okay he
taking
off all
right there we
go oh
[Music]
my this Like a Star Wars but
nut oh my I don't know how Rafa doesn't
get SE with
this
oh oh my that's
spooky
so how does that look to you it looks
good but uh the only one thing is that
the wondering alatos are much much
bigger they go slower when they do the
turns yeah you have to think like an
albatro just think like an albat feel
the wind yes feel the wind okay all
right all
right but to do
that you need the right
conditions good morning just going see
what the weather's
doing and it's another very beautiful
but flat calm day for the Southern Ocean
no big waves not
yet what we're really after is Big Wave
giant well so we can feel the power of
the ocean and flly within it pretty
much is pretty calm
[Music]
again compared to most people on the
ship we've got to be the only two
wishing for bigger
Seas
sometimes wishes do come true
we just woke up to some raw for
Seas which uh is what we want like look
at that look at
that it's going to be
[Music]
great at last Rafa can Flex his
wings basically just practicing the
moves filling out the
waves
wow and we can ride the
wind like an
[Music]
albatross
these aerial Giants can travel 70,000
miles in a
[Music]
year